a live-action winx club that will
definitely include
bloom and sky alright netflix you've got
our attention
say no more bloom you can always count
on us the wings club is about
tough-as-nails female fairies who
develop
unbreakable bonds while finding love and
fighting monsters
but the live-action version is less
colorful and includes fewer fairies
so is fate the winx saga going to blow
our alfian socks off
or leave us at the mercy of the burned
ones
we all know tv has a thing for dark and
gritty remakes
but is it always a good thing when it
comes to the winx club
it looks like netflix is focusing on a
more dramatic and less eccentric tale
of a group of young fairies as they try
to develop their powers and reach their
potential
but we can't help but wonder does that
mean fate
the winx saga will have little to do
with the original show beyond concept
and will its characters captivate us
like they used to the winx club
came out in 2004 but the series
continued right up until 2019.
there are some definite things the new
series has in common with its
predecessor
the story will focus on bloom played by
abigail cohen
whose powers have just started to
manifest it'll take place in the other
world and alfia will remain the boarding
school where a group of powerful young
fairies can train to earn their wings
and the specialists will be in charge of
guarding the realm
from some new threat called the burned
ones in a press release
netflix described the series as being
about a group of fairies who must learn
to master their magical powers while
navigating love
rivalries and the monsters that threaten
their very existence
obviously we're excited for the love
stories since we're still obsessed with
the winx club epic romances between
fairies and specialists
need a hand girls
in particular we notice that prince skye
will be a part of the series and played
by danny griffin
we can also spot riven played by freddie
thorpe the series was created by brian
young
who previously worked on the vampire
diaries so can we expect a bunch of
romantic high-stakes drama set amongst a
group of young adults
most definitely but since the fairies
are the focus of the original series
you'd think you'd see all of them
included in the reboot right
well that's actually not the case and in
fact these fairies seem to be almost
entirely different from the originals
what's similar is that the girls still
have their powers
there's water fairy ayesha played by
precious mustafa
mind fairy musa played by elisha
applebaum
and light fairy stella played by hannah
van der west tyson
there's also a new earth fairy named
tara played by elliot salt
who seems to be replacing flora for some
reason and then there's one character
technology fairy techna
who's missing from the reboot completely
which is pretty disappointing
but even with familiar powers it's the
way they use them that's so different
their clothing hair styling and entire
vibe are obviously pretty different too
brian young did that on purpose though
because he wanted to give the series a
dose of reality
one major perk of a live-action reboot
is that they can cast real girls with
different shapes and proportions
very different from the original fairies
giant eyes skinny outfits and
impossible bodies but without the colors
and flamboyant magic
it can be hard to see where the wink
saga gets all its winks from
after all is it just a show about
fairies or is it a show about the winx
club
since it's not animated young also opted
to create the magical other world in
ireland
the irish landscape gives fate its
connection to ancient fairy magic
and kind of feels like hogwarts for
fairies especially with the darker tones
in royal gate
plus the historical and epic looking
alpha
modernizing the other world also meant
getting rid of some of the gender roles
that brian young wasn't so crazy about
in the original
he explained that in our show boys can
be fairies
girls can be specialists which we're
totally on board with
we can already see some of the diversity
on campus there also
won't be any mean girl drama amongst the
fairy friends in this one
as young wants to leave all the cliquey
stuff back in the real world
as for enemies if the first few seasons
of the winx club are anything to go by
we might see the tricks or even lord
darker
though it's hard to say this early how
much the show might deviate from the
originals villains
the burned ones are the only specific
monsters mentioned by netflix so far
and they're a brand new addition despite
changes though young seems to have kept
the entire purpose of the winx club in
mind when creating this reboot
he mentioned it's always the thing that
makes you feel different
and like an outcast that is your gift to
the world fate
is meant to be a story of inclusion and
finding your power
and isn't that exactly the type of
lesson the winx club taught us when we
were kids
never in my life have i've been so happy
to have a fairy friend
you mean a fairy with magic powers who
can pack a good punch if need be
a few networks but netflix in particular
have really been getting a kick out of
remaking successful classic shows into
darker edgier series
just look at riverdale or the chilling
adventures of sabrina
which adds some grit to animated or
childhood content
but does it really work in these kinds
of shows there's usually a huge focus on
finding the reality within fantasy
we often see regular people going to
regular high schools for example
or living within the real world but they
have something dramatically different
and otherworldly about them
even in riverdale there's a distinct
sense that this isn't the real world
it's way too crazy and with so many
strange and terrible things happening
it's a clear escape from reality it's a
nice idea to make it more realistic
but it seems like other than names and a
concept there's not much visually
connecting the wink saga
to the winx club whereas in something
like riverdale the characters are
obviously stylistically based on the
archie comics characters
while it's also nice to see realistic
bodies fate
doesn't seem to have as much diversity
as we would expect from the very diverse
group of fairies in the original
like why is there no latina flora why
isn't musa asian
and why is technica missing completely
it's clear to see that these are very
different girls joining forces
but it would be nice to see a bit more
color since cultural diversity was one
of the things the winx club did so well
another question we have for all these
remakes is why darkness
where's all the fun it seems like tv's
new obsession
is with being edgy and dangerous but
some shows are campy for a reason
and it might have been nice to see the
live-action winx characters look just as
eccentric as their animated counterparts
shows like this likely do these dark
remakes because they want fans who watch
something when they were younger to be
intrigued by a more grown-up version
for example the charmed remake was
touted as being for fans
but in reality it feels like a show for
young adults that most original fans of
charmed are
actually too old for now it might draw
some people in because of nostalgia but
most of its fans are a new audience that
might have only caught up with the
original charmed after watching the
reboot
but of course that doesn't mean there's
no potential in a completely remade
series
like charmed the winx saga could be the
next great show about women with
incredible magical powers
replacing the recently canceled sabrina
abigail cohen was actually in sabrina as
dorcus
so it's fitting that she could carry the
torch for the next great female-powered
fantasy show
for younger audiences who want to enjoy
a colorful anime version
well the animated one still exists this
remake is supposed to be for people who
want more and want the series to grow
with them
so will fate the winx saga connect with
the winx club audience
or will it draw an entirely new audience
and still be successful
we think it depends on just how deep
they dive into these characters
motivations
and whether or not the burned ones are
terrible yet interesting villains that
keep us invested in the story
the winx club is about friendship
finding your power and coming together
so if they can get this vibe right even
with a darker and grittier look then the
winx girls could find themselves
fighting live-action enemies for many
years to come
do you think fate the winx saga will be
a hit do you plan on watching
let us know all your thoughts in the
comment section down below don't forget
to hit that like button while you're
here and subscribe to our channel for
more
thanks for watching